-Hey, everybody, welcome back.
So...
Our last "Corrections"
was a real humdinger,
if I do say so myself.
Everything really you want,
you could hope for,
out of an episode
of "Corrections."
There was a problem, though,
the only problem, really.
It snuck over
the 20-minute mark.
And while that's not
an issue per se,
it does --
There's a risk.
One of the stipulations
for the Emmy category
of this show
is that it averages
under 20 minutes.
So we now, having crept over,
we're gonna have to get it back
somewhere else.
It's just something
to keep our eye on,
because I think we can all agree
the only way
we're not winning Emmy gold
is due to
a [bleep] technicality.
[ Laughter ]
What is the category --
the category has a weird name.
Is it Best Dashed-Off
Thursday Bull[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
I'm happy to announce
some of you might be sad,
but we are now --
we have completed
the E.B. White arc
on "Corrections."
One thing we never
got to is what his initials
stand for, which, you know,
obviously we did
a bunch of scholarship.
The "B" stands for "B."
It's just the "B" is the "B."
The "E" on the other hand --
Oh, sorry.
We were talking
about the song "Stan,"
and in referencing that song,
I said,
"I wrote the address perfect."
It's -- you guys can't
figure this part
of "Corrections" out.
So many of you said,
the correct grammar is --
"I wrote
the address perfectly."
I was quoting lyrics.
So if you have
an issue with the grammar,
there are three people
you can take it up with --
Eminem,
Marshall Mathers...
[ Laughter ]
...Slim Shady.
Also, don't take it up with him.
Okay?
I mean, I'm in on this, right?
"Ha, ha. You said that wrong."
You think Eminem
wants corrections
from the likes of you?
Oh, Slim Shady, please stand up.
I guess we're ending our
sentences with prepositions now?
[ Laughter ]
There was some criticism --
I'm not gonna --
I said Stan
was the titular character
in the song "Stan."
And I was told it was --
he was the eponymous char--
I think both are fine.
I'm gonna die on that hill.
You know, a theme
of "Corrections" recently
has been, thanks
to the E.B. White saga,
which has completed...
[ Man chuckles ]
...but the theme
was typewritten letters.
And I was thinking,
you know, going back
and watching the "Stan,"
hearing the track
and watching the video,
it's very --
Eminem, again, a genius,
made a really good choice
to make them handwritten
with a pencil
instead of typewritten,
because the scratching of
the pencil underneath that track
is very haunting.
And I think that would not
have been the case
had it been
a typewritten letter.
And I wanted to prove it
so just take a listen,
see if you can
hear the difference.
-♪ You must not-a got'em ♪
[ Typewriter clacking ]
♪ There probably was a problem
at the post office ♪
♪ Or something ♪
♪ Sometimes
I scribble addresses ♪
♪ Too sloppy when I jot them ♪
♪ Anyway, what's been up, man?
How's your daughter? ♪
-Worse.
[ Light laughter ]
I loved the Super Bowl
halftime show.
I did.
Eminem, Kendrick,
Mary J. Blige, Snoop,
50 Cent.
I think that's everyone.
Ah! I forgot about Dre.
[ Laughter ]
I was just acting.
I didn't forget about Dre.
You know what's the most
interesting thing about Eminem?
Most rappers are Black,
but Eminem Be White.
That's his name.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
That's a a good transition
to the Beastie Boys.
I think about the Beastie Boys
all the time,
but I thought about them
a lot this week.
I was telling this to Shoemaker.
I thought about it
a lot this week
because Kaley Cuoco
was on the show.
And for whatever reason,
I just thought
if she was famous in 1989,
I'm pretty sure the Beastie Boys
would have had this line
in one of their songs.
♪ I got more rhymes
than Kaley Cuoco ♪
These aren't really corrections
anymore.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
"Lord of the Rings."
I feel like this
has gotten lost.
I've tried to establish this
every time
I talk about those books,
those films.
If you like them,
I'm so happy for you.
I am a fan of many things.
I think fandom
is a wonderful gift.
It's not for me, but I'm not --
I don't want to disabuse you
of your love of those things,
and I don't want to do anything
to make it seem like
it's frivolous, because, again,
I'm sure you would find
many of the things that I love
frivolous as well.
And with that said, I feel like
I've been hard on "Rings,"
and I do want to try to rectify
that a little today.
I implied -- I said
last time we were here
a couple weeks ago,
no major characters died
in "The Lord of the Rings"
films.
I forgot to mention
that a lot of people
who saw the films died
of natural causes
just due to, like, the length.
[ Light laughter ]
Boromir --
that was the character
the most people
were upset about.
Boromir died, and...
Boromir -- It was played --
not to be confused
with Bordomir.
Boromir was played by the great
British actor Sean Bean.
Sean Bean, though, famously dies
in most of his movies
and TV shows, so I feel like
it's easier to overlook,
in my defense.
This again --
This is more like
an interesting thing I caught
more than a correction.
I just want to clarify that,
like, you know,
for the Emmy voters.
Like, I know.
There was an interview
with Nic Cage --
he's got this great movie
coming out
I'm so excited to see --
where people said like,
"Hey, do you want to --
would you ever host 'SNL'?"
And he said, "You know who
should host 'SNL'
is Andy Samberg as me."
That's what he actually said.
This is -- you can look it up.
And I -- you know, I obviously
have some --
I think it's a great idea.
I have some pull with Lorne,
but I just --
first I want to make --
I want to even see
if Andy would be interested.
And again, this is never --
he never knows I'm calling,
so this could break either way.
[ Line ringing ]
Oh, he's not home.
I'll keep trying, though,
and that's a fun thing
to come back for.
[ Laughter ]
I have been --
I haven't been as critical
of graphics recently.
But we had this graphic
and "A Closer Look" on Monday.
That's an eagle...
smoking an e-cigarette
while checking its e-mail.
I'm gonna read you
the correction I got from this.
"The eagle would be typing
with its talons, not its wing.
E-cigarettes don't make
that much vapor.
The glasses wouldn't fit on
the eagle since it has no ears.
Eagles have the best eyesight
in the animal kingdom,
so there's no way
an eagle would need glasses.
If the glasses
were not the eagle's
but were facing him,
it implies the eagle
just sat down at someone else's
chair in the middle of a cafe
and usurped their computer
to check e-mails.
Who does that?"
[ Laughter ]
"In what country are you allowed
to vape indoors
in a cafe anyway?"
All very fair.
-I will say this is --
I can take a look again.
I didn't think this was a cafe.
I thought it was an office.
He might be like,
"Eagles in an office?"
But it's true. Sometimes there
are eagles in an office.
Like, one time Donald Trump
had an eagle in his office.
Take a look.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-And I didn't want to show that
because this isn't --
"Corrections" isn't political.
That's "A Closer Look,"
and Sal, though --
Sal was like,
"You gotta show the clip!"
And I'm like, "Sal, leave
'Corrections' alone, okay?
This isn't your bully pulpit."
Because I gotta be hon--
I don't --
a lot of that "Closer Look"
stuff is [bleep] crazy to me.
A lot of them I'm, like,
bullied into.
And he's like,
"You gotta show --
You gotta show the eagle video."
I'm like, "It's weird."
He's like, "You're complicit!"
Always with that.
Always.
But that's what --
and one of the nice things
about "Corrections" is,
because it's apolitical,
I think it's what
maybe people on the other side
of the aisle,
it's the part of our show
they engage with the most.
Which is good because --
this is a little awkward --
I have some corrections
for members of the right.
This -- I always get in trouble
because we say
that Trump hates windmills a lot
in "A Closer Look."
It is --
he does hate wind turbines,
but he calls them windmills.
So people are always like,
"Hey, man, you're talking about
wind turbines."
Like, we know, but I --
So hopefully if he's watching,
like, moving forward,
you know, hate what you hate,
but that's --
you're saying it wrong.
Oh, I also -- we talked about
how Ted Cruz was, you know,
basically saying that Disney --
Disney's rejection of Florida's
so-called "Don't Say Gay" bill
means that we're just, like,
a step away
from Mickey and Pluto
going at it.
And we made a joke about
now if you go on Google,
like, the autocomplete is,
you know,
"They go on a picnic,
go for a drive,
go to town on each other."
And people said, "Actually,
Google weeds out
suggestive phrases
in the autocomplete."
But not right now.
If you Google Mickey and Pluto,
thanks to Ted Cruz --
thanks to conservative
Senator Ted Cruz --
the number-one choice is --
right now the three are,
"Mickey and Pluto going at it,"
"Mickey and Pluto
getting it on,"
varsity jacket."
And I would just guess
that if you were think --
if you were on the fence
about that varsity jacket
and saw those first two,
might not want any more.
Samberg texted me.
Let's see what he has to say.
Hold on.
Mm.
Oh, he says,
"I'm in an edit meeting.
Did I miss 'Corrections'?"
I'm gonna try again.
"Edit meeting." He's always
like, "I'm in showbiz."
[ Line ringing ]
Bad day for him not to answer,
what with this time issue.
[ Line ringing ]
[ Cellphone dings ]
He just -- while I was
calling him, he texted,
"I'm still in the meeting."
[ Sputters ]
All right.
[ Laughing ]
And then he wrote --
'cause this ass [bleep]
every day --
he does Queen Bee every day.
That's him. See?
Like, he writes -- He gets a --
Wait. Is that -- yeah, can you
see it? There you go.
She gets Queen Bee every day
and then texts me
that he got it.
And so he wrote,
"In edit meeting.
Did I miss 'Corrections'?"
I wrote, "Still going."
And then I'm like,
what am I gonna do,
wait for him to --
I'll just call him.
He'll answer.
And he wrote,
"I'm still in the meeting.
Tell them I got Queen Bee."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, now a -- a quick, uh,
correction for...
Tucker Carlson did a special
about manhood,
and I guess there's a lot
about tanning your testicles.
A few people reached out, said,
you can't turn your testicles.
You can only tan your scrotum.
That's a really good point.
[ Laughter ]
No one's like, "I'm gonna get
these kidneys golden brown."
[ Laughter ]
That's a Tuck-up.
Um...
We said -- We made a joke about
microwaving your nutsack,
and more people than you would
think pointed out you can't --
the microwave only works
if you fully close the door,
so you can't...
microwave your nutsack.
So apologies to everybody
who was, you know,
looking forward to that.
And I guess we mentioned
something else
that a person wrote me,
"Bald eagles don't have
nutsacks.
They have cloacas."
And a way to remember that is,
in "Corrections,"
we fix our "mistakas."
♪ I got more balls
than an Eagles cloaca ♪
[ Light laughter ]
I guess I pronounce
the "t" in "often,"
which was very jarring
to people's ears.
And if you are someone
that bothered,
you can [bleep] right "oft."
[ Laughter ]
I am in very good mood today.
I got to go to my son's school
for the very first time today.
Because of COVID, I've never
been able to go inside.
He did this family tree thing,
and I went in.
It was very cute.
He had pictures
of everybody's family
and he described them all.
And one, it was just
cool to see your kid, like,
you know, talk to his class
and have confidence.
But the craziest thing was
at the end there was a Q&A,
and they said, "Do any of the
kids have questions for Ashe?"
And one of the kids asked him,
"How's Stefon?"
[ Light laughter ]
The mug.
We're working on the mug.
We don't have it yet.
We went to
the NBC merchandise people.
They're a little backed up.
They don't turn it around
super fast
when you have new merch.
I went down, you know,
to try to rattle the cage,
tried to get things sped up,
because obviously
I want you guys to be able
to buy this "Corrections,"
you know, the jackal mug.
And I went down.
It was a ghost town.
There was one guy wrapped up
in, like, a "Smash" blanket,
and...
[ Laughter ]
...he was like, "Oh!"
Like, he was sound asleep.
He's like, "Who are you?!"
And I was like,
"I'm Seth Meyers."
He's like, "From 'SNL'?"
And I'm like, "No, I have
the 'Late Night' show now.
He goes, "Well, I thought
that was Jimmy Fallon."
And I was like, "No, he's got --
he's 'The Tonight Show.'"
And he's like,
"What happened to Jay Leno?"
And I'm like, "He retired,"
and he's like, "Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "We just finished
the "JayWalking" Zune case.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about a brontosaurus.
I said brontosaurus.
People say, actually,
it's the Apatosaurus.
But then we decided
both are acceptable.
And then I ventured that
if we were, you know --
if we were allowed to sort of
change dinosaur names,
or agree on
a new dinosaur name,
maybe it was time to drop
the "p" in "pterodactyl."
Now, I was told
you couldn't do that
because "pter" -- p-t-e-r --
that means "wing."
"Dactyl" means "finger,"
and "ter" without the "p" --
"ter" means "earth,"
so it wouldn't be the same.
So just a reminder that
pterodactyl with a "p"
is a wing.
"Terodactyl" with a "t"
is earth.
So if you see a flying dinosaur,
that's a pterodactyl.
And if you see one walking on
the earth, that's terodactyl.
Mentioned Ben Warheit making
a mistake in one of his pieces.
And someone said, that's crazy
that he would make a mistake
because "Warheit"
means "truth" in German.
But in English it means
"hates to proofread."
[ Laughter ]
People have asked
how you spell Shoemaker.
Is it like Shoemaker
in the [indistinct],
or Schumacher -- is it spelled
like the German racecar driver?
This is also easy to remember
because Michael Schumacher
is one of the fastest --
traveled faster than almost
any human on Earth ever,
whereas Shoemaker is
on week four of using a cane
and somehow getting slower.
[ Laughter ]
Watching him move down a hallway
makes "Lord of the Rings" feel
like a Mountain Dew commercial.
[ Laughter ]
One piece of viewer mail.
"Hey, Seth, I noticed
you had some trouble
putting on your gloves.
I've been a lifeguard instructor
for many years,
and I find the easiest
and quickest way
to put on a pair of gloves
like that,
at least on a pool deck,
is to first fill them with water
and put your hand in,
letting your hands
displace the water.
I don't know if it'll help you
in your situation,
but lifeguard students
have a timed skill
that involves putting on gloves,
and I wanted to
pass that along."
Why do you put on gloves?
[ Laughter ]
Uh, I just want to say --
hopefully this is
legally binding --
if you're a lifeguard
and I ever need CPR, skip it.
[ Light laughter ]
This is a book update.
It was really cool.
"The New York Times"
sent this over.
And they made this, obviously.
It's pretty cool.
It's a way to track
how your book is doing.
And I want to --
I have some exciting --
this is week five.
So week one,
we were number three.
Okay, that's cool.
And then we were...
...number four in week two.
Okay. Here we go, like that.
It's weird that they didn't know
what size to make these.
And then where do we end up?
Week three, we were number six.
This is bad.
I mean, it's so nice
for "The New York Times"
to send this over,
but this is embarrassing and I'm
sorry I'm doing this, then.
They -- the back --
they obviously didn't --
they got their --
they eyeballed it wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Paper of record?
And then it was number eight.
And then this is --
you might notice a trend,
which is why this is going to
surprise you guys.
Week five...
it's number nine.
Let me say something.
Lot of Easter books on the list.
And the gravy train
just left town...
...for the Easter books.
Also, if you bought
a Easter book last week,
that's like the way you say,
like,
"I forgot to get you a basket."
How'd we do on time,
"Schumacher"?
-20--
-Ah, [bleep]. 20?
-21.
-[ Sputters ]
Maybe...
...cut the Beastie Boys stuff?